to all the men out there that being beat  by women if there's a camera knock her  the hell out because I if he knew that  there was a camera there and after all  that resisting one bit slap and she  would have been down and as far as I'm  concerned it's all on camera  so I can understand now why people would  do things in front of cameras why they  want cameras out to protect themselves  because as far as I'm concerned if  you're getting abused and you're worried  about how it's going to seek because  there's enough cameras I know it's  America but in the UK everywhere you go  you're covered by a camera you can't go  nowhere that cover so as far as I'm  gonna say if somebody slaps you and it's  on the camera slap her back but make  sure you give it hard so when you slap  her  break her neck or drop her on the floor